If you're watching this channel,
you're probably into technology.
You might even be thinking about a career
in technology.
Well, today we have a special guest,
Tina Williams, a woman to technology
who wants to share some of her sage
career advice, starting with “skills”.
So in the area of skills,
I think what you can
evaluate is
whether you want to go deep or broad.
So when I mean by deep
is that you may decide to enter technology
and you have a specific love
of a specific area,
and you want to become the subject matter
expert there and devote your career.
And I've seen a lot of women
do that successfully and rise up
and become distinguished
engineers and submit many patents.
It's a really great way to
to have your career.
For me, I started out as a developer.
I was coding in assembler and PL/I long,
long time ago
and I got to the point where I wanted more
and I wanted to experience new things,
so I wanted to be more involved
with clients.
I moved over into consulting.
I then moved over into business
development
and then on into marketing and eventually
found my way back to software.
And now I am a product manager.
So I've taken all of those experiences
along the way to apply now
to being a product manager.
Oh, that's a great way
of starting deep
and then using that as a springboard
into new sort of areas of technology.
That brings us to the next one,
which is called “leave”.
What's that about that?
Well, it's not really about leaving.
It's about thinking about when you get in,
if you're going to be moving
from different area to a different area,
thinking about your end game.
So I always think about...
Like the next job is what you're saying, right?
Right. So I'm working my way out of my current
position into what I'm going to do next.
You know, leaving open the door
for me to go do something else.
And that's really gets back to my desire
to be creative and innovative.
That's really where I'm drawn to
and starting new initiatives
or transformations.
And so once I have that all in place
and I have everything
operational, it's time to move on to something else.
So that's one way you can approach
your career,
is to think about that
as you're going into a new job.
I also think it makes you less controlling
and more collaborative, also
because you're thinking about handing it
over.
In fact,
I would argue that, at least in my career,
I've always said every 2 to 3 years
you want to be thinking about moving on
to a new role, a new responsibility,
if anything, just to keep you being a more
well-rounded employee with more education,
more knowledge that you can share.
That brings us then to “messy”.
So messy.
That's really to me
about getting your hands dirty.
So as I moved around from different job
to different job,
there was always a new type of technology
that I was working with.
And so in order to become comfortable
and confident in that area,
I first took the time to really understand
the technology.
And so, for instance,
I was a product manager within IBM.
I was rolling--helping to roll out a new
CMS system across all of our
global organizations.
And so first, before enabling
all of those different teams,
I took the time to really understand it
myself
and actually be able to use the platform
myself.
And now today
I'm involved in an area of AI,
and so I'm taking the time now
to really understand that platform,
get my hands
dirty, understand how it works,
and therefore much more confident
when I talk to my colleagues and clients
You are also are a lot more authentic
because you have experience with it,
not just from reading but doing.
That's great.
So “elevator",
that's a rather obscure title.
What's that about?
So it ties in with the rest.
Whereas
if you want to move around in your career,
you're not likely to do that
without getting to know people.
So a great way to get to know
people is to talk to them in the elevator,
which isn't intuitive
or always considered normal or proper.
But for me, I've met lots of people
in the elevator at all different levels.
My peer colleagues
and then also executives.
And I find that people are very willing
to talk about themselves
and what area they're in.
And I've learned so much
about different areas to explore
that I would have never found out
about otherwise.
In fact, that's how Tina and I met--she
was walking by the studio.
We got to talking about career and I
said, “Why don't you come on and tell us
more about it?” So I'm really glad
that you did reach out like that.
Well, you get the final word
with the category “more”.
So this is
something I just think about for all women
and really for a lot of professionals
is that it's always good to ask for more.
Like always ask for what you want,
always ask about
new areas, always ask for more money
if that's what you think you deserve.
I always ask for new opportunities.
If you don't ask, then no one knows.
No one knows that you care.
And they may just...
It's not that they don't
respect or appreciate you,
but they may not prioritize you.
It reminds me of something
one of my mentors actually said
is that “you are your own best advocate,”
so you need to be one.
Well, you get the final word
offering advice to the ladies out there
who are thinking about technology.
What would you say to them?
I would just say
technology has been a great career for me.
I've had opportunities to learn,
which is something I really enjoy.
I've had opportunities
to fly all over the world
and meet all kinds of wonderful people
through technology.
And it's just been a great career.
Excellent! Well,
thank you very much, Tina.
Hey, before you guys leave,
be sure to hit like and subscribe.
And also if you'd like to see some other
topics, leave us comments below.
Thank you.
Thanks for watching.
Before you leave, please
remember to hit like and subscribe.